a new book where all books can be
acquired written by ian o'connor coach k
the rise and the rise and reign of mike
shashefsky the author right here on the
rich eisen show ian o'connor back again
how you doing ian
good rich thanks for having me
congratulations congratulations you bet
uh congrats on yet another must read for
the sports fan near you thank you you
bet so um you did not get coach k's
um participation but a bunch of people
participated i imagine cause they had a
check with him first is that the way
that works and this one for you he said
rich that he would not block anybody and
he actually spoke about this yesterday
at a press conference and he didn't uh
when i did the belichick book bill did
uh try to block everybody
so
that was a little bit more of a
challenging process and i think the
patriots are a little more secretive
than duke i would say the patriots are
the kremlin and duke is uh the cia i
guess but okay no yeah it it uh he he
didn't grant any interviews i believe he
wants to do his own book in retirement
so
why should he give ian o'connor his
stories for free without editorial
control and frankly i don't have a good
answer to that question right so i don't
necessarily blame him for that but it
was nice of him to not block anybody
else so
i had access to his best friends his
closest assistants and aides and players
over the years and
and actually duke did help facilitate
some interviews so i was appreciative of
that okay so what did you learn about
coach mike
that you did not know going in obviously
his
his story has been well chronicled from
uh you know army and bob knight being
uh his coach all the way to the present
day uh what did you learn here let me
start with something i learned uh more
than 20 years ago and and you may have
experienced this rich and i don't know
how many uh viewers and listeners have
but sitting near the the duke bench
right behind it for the first time in 99
the sweet 16 game in the meadowlands of
new jersey against steve alford and
southwest missouri state for two hours
and 15 minutes it was the most profane
i mean i just couldn't believe the
profanity out of his mouth he's by far
the most profane coach i've ever been
around
and i wasn't offended morally or
anything because i cursed a decent
amount i was entertained but i mean
everyone from the rest
his own players to his assistant coaches
he blasted quinn snyder profanely a
couple of times who was an assistant at
the time with duke and so uh it was
amusing but a lot of people have lived
that experience for the first time and
then have decided never to sit next to
the duke bench ever again
so
uh there are a lot of grandmothers in
america who love this guy if they
actually sat next to that bench they
would be uh pretty mortified but
as far as after uh talking to hundreds
of people for this book i think the one
thing that stands out to me as a as a
surprise is
when i ask players how important the
pristine or or relatively pristine
perception of the duke program as the
last
shining city on the corrupt hill that is
major college athletics is how important
is that to mike
and to a man the player said
yeah he cares about that but really it's
nothing close to winning all he cares
about is beating you that day whoever
you are
and and i was i thought it'd be more of
a 50 50 split
but
all the players said that that really
yeah it's nice to have that image as a
relatively clean program and doing it
the right way
but at the end of the day all mike cares
about is beating you and i think that's
why he has nearly 1200 victories
it's having that philosophy about the
game and about life man the the number
of players that he has turned out uh
from duke into the professional ranks
ian o'connor are too many to mention and
certainly some of the greats
of all time and then the personalities
that he has had to manage collegiately
but also at the olympic level is quite
something and that's a story that i saw
uh in an excerpt as well as on your
twitter account that i'd love to you to
recount here was when he was in the
beijing games in 08 and the young lebron
james demanded
coach k to rectify whatever was going on
with kobe bryant and between the two of
them i give you the floor on this one
well rich yeah kobe uh was taking some
laker shots
that weren't very team-centric
and it built up a little bit over time
players started to grumble about it and
so the last preliminary game in shanghai
against australia he took a couple not
too many but
lebron had hit the breaking point with
it
and coach k was all about accountability
shared accountability within that team
so he held lebron accountable on some
things so lebron decided you know what
i'm going to hold shishevsky accountable
on this
so he
passes by him near the team usa bench
and according to someone who heard it
directly
he said yo coach you better fix that
mother blank
and of course he was talking about kobe
bryant so now strzewski has to deal with
this and he wants no part of it as a
college coach his first olympic games he
does not want to rebuke the great kobe
bryant but he has to and he has to show
lebron that he's willing to do that so
the next day
with trepidation he approached kobe and
he took him into a side room he opened
up his laptop
and i don't know maybe he had six or
seven shots on there and he told
toby these are bs shots
you can't do this you could do this with
the lakers but you can't take these
shots when lebron and melo and and kid
and these other guys are your teammates
these are the best players in the world
so they don't deserve that
and uh so we need you to make this
change and approach
so kobe looked at them and i don't have
the the book page in front of me so i'm
paraphrasing a little bit but basically
said
okay it won't happen again coach and
and that was the end of the meeting and
it didn't happen again and kobe bailed
them out against spain in the gold medal
game and actually with a couple of
acrobatic shots so it was kind of
interesting the way it played out but
but shishevsky and then chaszewski let
lebron know hey i took care of it so you
see lebron holding coach k accountable
coach k holding kobe accountable
and they won their first of uh well two
gold medals together as a group and then
of course coach k went on to
to win a third in rio
what's in your book if you don't mind um
about coach k kicking the tires on the
nba and why he never went what'd you
find out well and he thought seriously
about the celtics in 90. i think he got
the sense that he hadn't won the big one
yet and he wanted to do that he kept he
was he was marv levy before there was
marv levy uh losing the big one and so
he hadn't won the national title yet he
also sensed that dave gavitt wanted him
and red auerbach wasn't sure about
hiring a college coach
and then in 2004 kobe really recruited
him to to coach the lakers he took that
very seriously i would say that was
probably rich the closest he came to
actually leaving
duke but as it turned out by staying he
got the best of both worlds he got to
control winning more as you can in
college because when you win in college
you get the best players to still come
to you in the nba when you win you pick
last in the draft so
he got that he kept that and then he
also got a chance to coach the best nba
players in the world at three olympic
games so
so really it worked out perfectly for
him
and actually that olympic experience
changed him and
inspired him to gravitate more towards
the one and done players after beijing
he changed all of a sudden he went after
john wall kentucky got him okay then he
gets kyrie irving he gets austin rivers
who was a slam dunk one and done at the
time he gets jabari parker so that that
olympic experience and coming home back
to duke telling himself i really just
want to coach the best players in the
world at that level
that really inspired him to embrace one
and done what did you discover about his
relationship
whatever it might have been with dean
smith
when uh when that rivalry between duke
and north carolina certainly got a
jolt of adrenaline what do you think it
was he had a better relationship a
closer relationship with roy williams
dean smith was so established when mike
arrived right
he needed to
try to try to fight that and just fight
for his place in that world in his
backyard and so they were never really
friendly i think near the end of dean
smith's life
they came together some
and but but he had a better relationship
with roy williams and because they were
rory was at a different stage in his
career when he got the carolina job and
so was mike
and uh but dean smith he certainly had
great respect for what he accomplished
but the first time they ever coached
against each other
it was in the final seconds of a game
that carolina basically had one and dean
smith went over to shake his hand
and mike wouldn't shake it he said the
game's not over dean
and roy williams watched that and said
you know what this guy is going to be
difficult to deal with
roy meant that as a compliment yes no i
know you know what yeah don't do don't
do that to a legend like dean smith your
first time out don't then he said you
know what mike's right the game wasn't
over
and and now we're gonna have to deal
with this guy and they certainly did so
dean didn't go up to him with his finger
pointing and saying i'm not going to
forget that that didn't happen
that didn't happen i had another thing
later on where dean was mad he punched
the scorers table and he added 20 points
to the carolina score total by accident
and shizki flipped out about that
and he railed about a double standard in
the acc one for dean smith remember of
course of course and now that it's it's
the duke double standard so she said yes
later
that is i do remember that i remember
when he was complaining that you know
dean smith like if i had done it there'd
be a big problem right and then i do
remember that a double standard now
here's coach k
you know uh in his final year so how do
you think he's approaching the next six
weeks
well hey one one note to add to that roy
williams did tell me after the olympic
experience he got more phone calls from
coaches complaining about the recruiting
advantage that mike szyszewski was
getting by coaching team usa that he
could count he said it was a crazy
amount of people i don't know why they
called me to complain about it because
i'm the one who's paying the price for
it more than anybody but but he did make
that observation i think hey duke has a
chance to win the whole thing paulo
bancaro has to carry them he's got to
get more aggressive and obviously if he
goes out the way john wooden did that
would be a fairytale ending to
to an iconic career
and and then he rides off to the sunset
now i think he will still be fairly
involved in this program with john
shires head coach i he's not a man with
many hobbies he doesn't play golf like
roy williams he he does a little
gardening and he's not a big reader
so i i think he's going to keep his
office at duke and i think he's going to
be involved in the basketball program
okay that's cool um before i let you go
so you've written books about coach k
now in theory where books can be
acquired right now
belichick jeter right
um arnie and jack you wrote about them
correct
um is there
any through line
between these champions that you've
noticed
any particular trait
that you've noticed in everybody that
you've kind of done a story on or you've
done a book on
ian o'connor the obvious i guess is
competitive there's a there's there's a
competitive arrogance in there that that
they have i mean beyond work ethic
attention to detail and all those things
that just an unbending belief in
themselves that they could get it done
and i i think it's best captured by i
was at the latener game when duke beat
kentucky in 92 in the philly spectrum
and that's probably the greatest play in
college basketball history and i was
sitting courtside for that after the
game in the press conference i asked
mike zizewski what did you tell your
team in that final huddle before grant
hill threw the ball to leightoner with
2.1 seconds left
and he said we're going to win the game
and he made them believe that on the way
back to the huddle some players told me
they were thinking about the beach and
playing golf and the season was over
they were one and done they won the
national title in 91 now we're not going
to repeat the season's over and in that
huddle he got them to believe they could
actually win the game and they did it so
i think that's what separates the greats
of the great
from really everyone else you could say
the same thing about
tiger
and obviously jordan people i have not
done biographies on but
tom brady they're serial killers and i
think that the people i've written about
here have that
quality competitive arrogance
competitive arrogance write that down
for a fantasy football team name that's
a very good one competitive arrogance
and we have a whole bunch of avatar uh
possibilities with all the books that
you've written ian o'connor i appreciate
the time uh before i let you go how do
you think belichick is uh taking uh you
know seeing his name in a lawsuit um
with brian flores and his text
to flores that was meant um well i was
meant for floors he just forgot i guess
he hit the wrong brian in his in his
contact list
right it was meant for table right and
so i think he's kicking himself over
making a pretty bad and careless mistake
i do think flores is the right guy to
lead that cause it's obviously a major
problem right rule doesn't work at all
but yes i think that uh he is uh he has
kicked himself every day since he sent
that text to the wrong brian no i'm just
i know i know that i'm just wondering
what he thinks about being involved in
in this lawsuit
with that yeah i'm sure it's unsettling
and really i mean bill deserves credit
he's the one who molded flores into a
good nfl head coach who never deserved
to be fired in the first place bill
raised him in the system
and really shaped him into a great
defensive coach who held the high
scoring rams to three points in a super
bowl as the lead defensive coach on that
staff
so to be involved in this mess and brian
flores be a part of it and bill looks
like one of the villains when
it's really questionable whether or not
that that should be the case right
yeah i i think it's a tough one for him
no i mean and i i don't i don't it's
unfortunate if he's viewed as a villain
i mean he just reached out to uh some
you know uh a a colleague who he wanted
to congratulate and um he sent it to the
wrong brian i honestly think he meant
flores and then um and and then he
realized it was a different brian that
he should have been sending it to i
don't know but
it's a terribly unfortunate send that's
for sure um ian i appreciate the time
thank you thanks so much richard you got
it ian o'connor everybody uh go buy his
book um about coach k the rise and reign
of mike szyszewski hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here